maintenant trois baleines noires sont
présentement empêtré dans des cordages
dans le golfe du saint laurent c'est une
situation qui commence à être vraiment
préoccupante pour les autorités dans la
mesure où ces baleines ont été retrouvé
mort dans les eaux canadiennes depuis le
début de l'année donc kim pêches et
océans canada qui dit surveiller la
situation de près surtout l'état des
mammifères des baleines
il faut savoir que la première baleine
empêtré a été repéré il ya une semaine
exactement le 29 juin dernier
l'animal avait une corde autour de la
cus semblait traîner quelque chose de
lourd
également elle a été repérée donc tout
près du nouveau brunswick tout près de
l'île de miscou ici par la suite jeudi à
deux autres baleines qui ont été repérés
la première par des représentants de
transports canada à l'est de la gaspésie
la deuxième tout près de miscou par un
chercheur en mer et là l'histoire se
répète les animaux étaient empêtrés dans
des cordes
maintenant effectivement le ministère
des pêches et des océans du canada
envisagent la possibilité justement de
tenter de sauver ces baleines peut-être
d'accrocher des boues et de repérage sur
ces animaux mais faut savoir que c'est
une opération qui est extrêmement risqué
vous comprendrez en raison de la taille
de la force également du comportement de
ces animaux pour vous donner une idée
donc mills à une baleine comme celle a
pu mesurer jusqu'à 14 mètres de long
peut peser jusqu'à 70 milles kg
lorsque l'animal atteint l'âge adulte et
on sait qu'ils aiment que la population
bas la noire vraiment diminué dans les
dernières années alors jusqu'à
maintenant on compte à peu près 400
baleines dans l'atlantique nord
si selon un rapport qui avaient été
publiées en 2018 au stick les
principales causes de mortalité baisse
et l'enchevêtrement dans les engins de
pêche également les collisions avec les
bateaux ça si selon le consortium north
atlantic right way je terminerai en vous
disant qu' à certaines mesures qui ont
été mises en place par transports canada
notamment la réduction de la vitesse de
la limite de vitesse pour les navires de
plus de 20 mètres également il ya des
zones où là on a fermé justement la
pêche merci beaucoup qui aime vous en
prie